bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de l'iphone 9 alors effectivement la
question pourrait paraître qui peu
prématuré appareils de toutes les
rumeurs sur l'iphone neuf mais pourtant
il ya un vrai sens l'iphone 10 l'iphone
8 et 8 plus vient à peine d'être annoncé
par apple qu'on parle déjà effectivement
du futur iphone 9 alors pourquoi tout
simplement parce qu'avec l'iphone 10 on
a vraiment entraperçu l'avenir des
nouveaux iphone et on va vraiment passé
à tout autre chose
je suis monsieur grue pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ma chaîne parle de
stratégie de stratégie digitale
stratégie youtube et de tous les objets
d' influence qui vous permettront
d'aller plus loin dans votre vie
digitale vous avez d'ailleurs à vous
abonner à la chaîne et activer la cloche
pour ne manquer aucune publication ce
que nous annonce l'iphone 10
c'est la fin de tous ces smartphones la
du 3gs qui a fait son temps vraiment
aucune forme qui est un petit peu
obsolète du 4 du 5 c'est du 6 s duceppe
du 8c la fin de cette gamme d'iphone à
la place qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver on
va déjà passé avec des grands écrans
oled c'est la fin du lcd pour les iphone
très clairement ils ont fait leur temps
peut les en remercier et leur a dit au
revoir à la place ils s'approvisionnent
maintenant avec des écrans oled
à noter que les écrans oled de l'iphone
x sont fournies par leurs grands
concurrents sud coréens samsung toujours
un peu compliqué pour une boîte comme
apple de faire travailler son concurrent
principal directement samsung
electronics fourni sur son iphone 10 les
fameuses écran ils sont les seuls
aujourd'hui en capacité à fournir des
écrans en masse ailleurs selon une info
du site économique coréen the store
apple aurait déjà passé commande de plus
de 180 millions d'écrans pour son futur
smartphone de 2018
bien évidemment à priori ce serait
samsung met à peu une autre idée
derrière la tête
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui les
écrans oled voulais retrouver sur les
samsung est sûre les lg a priori lg n'a
pas la capacité industrielle de
fabriquer autant d'écrans oled que
samsung met à peu je soutiendrai lg afin
qu'il puisse produire davantage d'écrans
oled en grande quantité alors pour
quelle raison tout simplement parce que
si vous avez deux concurrents dans la
course
les prix
des écrans oled vont baisser il faut
savoir que pour les iphone 10,1 d'écrans
oled coûte à peu près entre 120 à 130
dollars pour un smartphone qui vendu 999
dollars ça représente à peu près 12 % du
prix de vente c'est quand même
conséquent si lg et samsung pourrait
être en concurrence les prix baisseront
mécaniquement ça serait soit apple qui
pourrait augmenter sa marge soit les
prix des téléphones qui baisseraient qui
donnerait beaucoup plus concurrentiel
d'ailleurs pour la petite info il faut
savoir que l'action de samsung à grimper
lorsque l'iphone dit ses sorties qu'il a
été plutôt bien accueilli par le public
le coût de fabrication des écrans lcd
quand avait été de 50 dollars il y avait
une vraie concurrence entre plusieurs
entreprises asiatiques à peu le jouer
sur la concurrence permet effectivement
de tirer les prix vers le bas alors
qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver dans ses
nouveaux iphone la nouveauté va être la
taille de l'écran
a priori va y avoir de nouveaux
smartphones qui va sortir en 2010 8,1
avec un écran de 5,28 pouces et un de 6
46 pouces ils devraient tous les deux
équipés du nouveau processeur à 12
permettrait d'ailleurs encore plus loin
dans la réalité augmentée dans le temps
de calcul dans l'optimisation de votre
matériel pour la création de cette puce
ce serait soit 7 et taïwanaise tsmc qui
crée effectivement des puces depuis de
nombreuses années pour apple soit
samsung on parle effectivement de
samsung qui pourrait créer la nouvelle
puce du prochain iphone
le touch à lille aurait complètement
disparaître des iphone à venir au profit
du fays heidi il y avait une rumeur
persistante au niveau de l'iphone 10 à
savoir qu'on aurait pu avoir un bouton
home virtuelle sous l'écran a priori la
technologie n'aurait pas été
suffisamment bien développée pour
pouvoir le mettre sur ce smartphone est
ce qu'il y en aura une sur les prochains
smartphones en complément du fail saïdi
c'est une question qui reste en suspens
ce qui est sûr aujourd'hui c'est que le
faith heidi va s'imposer
et de toute façon le touch heidi est
voué à disparaître
selon macrumors lg pourrait développer
les batteries du futur iphone des
batteries y en a elles qui prendrait
moins de place à l'intérieur et qui
permettrait vraiment d'optimiser le
hardware de ce smartphone un smartphone
qui pourrait être proposée en 64 giga
250 gigas mais également en 512
il ya bien évidemment il conserverait un
chargement sans fil à l'induction de
toute façon le chargement avec un câble
étant effectivement voué à disparaître
et faire partie du passé comme tous ces
anciens iphone au niveau de la caméra on
retrouve a toujours un grand angle et un
téléobjectif ont montré encore en
qualité pour vraiment gagner en
luminosité et en qualité soit sur vos
vidéos ou sur vos photos et bien
évidemment la réalité augmentée sera
toujours plus présent tim cook adore la
réalité augmentée il misé dessus alors
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu gadget on
avait effectivement les représentations
où on peut se voir jouer à des jeux en
trois dimensions déplaçant au tour mais
il faut vraiment considérer ça comme une
avancée technologique majeure la réalité
augmentée va être omniprésente vous
allez retrouver quand vous allez faire
vos courses au supermarché vous aurez
plus d'informations sur vos produits
lorsque vous irez voir une exposition
vous aurez davantage d'informations dans
toutes les choses de votre quotidien la
réalité augmentée sera présent
aujourd'hui on est encore ce quelque
chose de très gadget mais dites vous
bien que d'ici quelques années sera
complètement impossible de passer à côté
de la réalité augmentée
alors quid de la réalité virtuelle il y
avait une rumeur qui avait circulé il ya
quelques temps sur l'iphone de 2018 on
aurait pu retrouver effectivement des
petits connecteurs sur le smartphone
pour le plus gai dans un casque de
réalité virtuelle pour l'instant il a
priori pas plus de rumeurs concrète à ce
point mais la réalité virtuelle quelque
chose qui va aussi énormément développés
on peut très bien imaginer d'ailleurs
d'abord un casque de réalité virtuelle
qui vous permettra d'avoir de la réalité
augmentée mains libres vous maîtrisez
votre casque de réalité virtuelle votre
smartphone bien évidemment ce trait
dessus et vous pourriez voir dans votre
pièce grâce à la caméra de votre
smartphone sexe toujours eu sur les
samsung j'ai pu l'essayer
la qualité n'est pas encore au top et on
a rapidement la nausée mais imaginez que
si vous aviez une qualité exceptionnelle
au niveau de votre caméra avec un écran
oled est rendue comme si vous n'aviez
pas de casque ça vous permettra de
superposer
directement des objets d'avoir une
réalité augmentée encore plus
intéressante ça vous évitera bien
évidemment c'est une herbe smartphone à
la main comme ça là pour en profiter
vous auriez votre casque sur la tête
effectivement ça se passe dans la rue où
une exposition on aura tous rapidement
les remettre avec notre gros casque mais
ça peut être vraiment intéressant ça
peut vraiment avoir un sens il ya aussi
un autre projet qui existe c'est le
projet d apple glace on se retrouverait
effectivement avec des lunettes tout
permettrait d'avoir de la réalité
augmentée
j'ai essayé il ya pas longtemps
d'ailleurs à l'ifa berlin le casque de
réalité augmentée de microsoft on en
reparle très bientôt
mais c'est vrai que c'est intéressant la
technologie n'est pas encore hyper hyper
développé mais c'est vraiment bluffant
sont pareils très très très bientôt
restez connecté à la chaîne la grande
question qui se pose maintenant c'est
comment vont s'appeler les iphone du
futur très clairement avec l'arrivée de
l'iphone disent on va très bien que la
dénomination classique des iphone est
morte 6,6 s7 pas 17 directement 8,8 plus
et là l'iphone 10 il est clair que le
nom d iphone avec une numérotation
derrière ces morts ils vont pas nous
proposer un iphone 9 l'année prochaine
alors que l'iphone 10 est sorti cette
année et on va pas arriver directement
l'iphone rose ça n'aurait globalement
pas de sens alors qu'est ce que cela
peut bien vouloir dire pour apple alors
très clairement si on va chercher un
petit peu dans l'histoire d'apple et
dans l'histoire des produits d'apple et
notamment de mac os
on a probablement des éléments de
réponse si vous êtes comme moi des
utilisateurs d'apple vous savez très
bien que les bacs os avant vous aviez le
mac os 8 le mac os 9
vous aviez des mises à jour avec le 9
points devant nous des choses comme ça
voilà cette vieille machine qui est un
petit peu un vieux dinosaures de plus
chez apple c'est le dernier qui a tourné
avec 1 9 point de me semble-t-il à
l'époque est le premier sur lequel j'ai
installer un os 10 il se pourrait qu'il
se passe exactement la même chose sur
les iphone par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé sur les mac os à savoir vous aviez
les versions 8 la version 9 l arrivée
ensuite de mac os x mac os 10 et après
vous avez une déclinaison mac os x 1 2
3 4 cheetah puma jaguar panther 10.4
tiger 10.5 leopard 10.6 snow leopard
10.5 laguiole mountain laguiole
mavericks yosemite elle capitale sierra
haïtien pourrait se passer exactement la
même chose pour les iphone on peut très
bien imaginer avoir un iphone 10 ensuite
que vous n'ayez poudre de numérotation
mais des noms qui permettent de les
reconnaître
on pourrait imaginer un iphone jaguar un
iphone mavericks l'iphone yosemite ça
serait probablement plus sympa travaillé
qu'un simple numéro de toute façon va
pas se retrouver avec l'iphone 31
l'iphone 32 f1 il ya un moment cette
numérotation n'a plus réellement de sens
ce serait des iphone qui serait moins
cher par rapport à aux prix aujourd'hui
de l'iphone 10 on serait normalement en
dessous des 1000 dollars
le problème principal aujourd'hui du
coût de ce smartphone ce sont les écrans
oled le coût de fabrication est beaucoup
trop élevé si il y à une concurrence qui
s'installe dans les années à venir si lg
arrive à se développer et à produire à
grande échelle on devrait avoir des
iphone beaucoup moins cher parce que
c'est aussi la clé stratégique pour
apple samsung maîtrise la chaîne de
fabrication de ces écrans donc forcément
ils vont proposer des smartphones un peu
moins cher bien que si on regarde bien
le galaxy s suit ensuite plus celle de
suite sont quand même relativement cher
mais par contre sans le son sera
toujours plus concurrentiel puisque ils
n'ont pas de sous traitants pour leurs
écrans et que ce sont leurs propres
écrans si apple veut rester
concurrentiels par rapport à samsung ils
vont de fait de voir baisser les prix
d'achat de leur écran donc on peut
imaginer un prix autour des 1000 dollars
peut-être un petit peu moins pour
l'écran 5,28 pousse tout ça reste bien
sûr encore hypothétique il est un petit
peu trop tôt pour avoir des informations
précises dessus un produit qui a priori
sortirait au mois de septembre 2018
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous
vous êtes séduit aujourd'hui par cet
iphone 8 est ce que vous envisageriez de
l'acheter alors très clairement si vous
avez un iphone 7 qui est récent à mon
sens moins que vous soyez vraiment un
gros gros fan de réalité augmentée ça
vaut pas nécessairement le coup
d'acheter l'iphone 8 aujourd'hui
d'autant plus que l'année prochaine il
ya vraiment tout autre chose les
nouveaux produits iphone 10 vont se
répandre et si vous achetez aujourd'hui
un iphone 8
il va être très rapidement obsolète si
par contre vous avez un iphone 5 c'est
un iphone 5 et un iphone 6 6 est ce ça
peut voir un coup de passer sur 1,8 si
vous avez besoin d'une bonne qualité au
niveau de la caméra si vous avez besoin
d'un processeur un petit peu plus rapide
dites moi ce que vous en pensez aux
commentaires est ce que vous envisagez
de changer votre iphone si oui pour
lequel et qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ce que pourrait être l'iphone 9 l'iphone
10 cheetah et l'iphone 10 jaguar enfin
on sait pas trop mettez moi tous ces
commentaires on en discute ensemble
quant à moi je vous remercie d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je vous invite à
vous abonner à la chaîne restera
toujours plus de contenu pour réussir
votre vie digitale que ce soit votre
stratégie youtube que ce soit pour
connaître les nouveaux produits d'
influence les nouvelles fonctionnalités
intéressantes
abonnez vous à ma chaise je vous
remercie beaucoup d'abord regarder cette
vidéo si vous avez des questions vous
pourrez être jaune sur twitter @
monsieur brouille avec le hashtag hast
monsieur heureux quant à moi je vous dis
à très bientôt d'ici là portez vous bien
ça lui
[Musique]